gerade die pressekonferenz in berlin
geht jetzt los wir schalten jetzt sofort
mal rüber über die ergebnisse ihrer
beratungen
die heute zusammen mit anderen
vertretern der bundesregierung hier
zusammengekommen sind
ohnehin braucht ihre physischen treffen
ich glaube das war auch gut denn wir
sind in einer phase der pandemie die
ernst ist ein einleitender vortrag des
epidemiologen michael meyer hermann hat
uns auch noch einmal aufgezeigt in
welcher phase wir sind glaube das war
recht einleuchtend und auch hilfreich
ich bin überzeugt das war es auch schon
jetzt in diesen tagen und wochen die
kommen tun und was wir nicht tun wird
entscheidend sein für die frage wie wir
durch diese pandemie kommen denn wir
sehen ja dass die kurven der
infektionszahlen nach oben weisen zum
teil recht steil und dass wir ein sehr
hohes infektionsgeschehen in einigen
regionen deutschlands haben und wir
befinden uns in einer anderen jahreszeit
damals im märz stand der frühling vor
der tür
jetzt gehen wir sozusagen auf die
wintermonate zu
das hat zur folge dass die kontakte im
innern natürlich sehr viel häufiger sind
das für weniger draußen stattfinden kann
und das bedeutet natürlich dass wir auch
vor größeren herausforderungen stehen
unser gemeinsames ziel so haben wir es
heute auch beschlossen ist dass wir die
kontakte nach verfolgen wollen
das gelingt großen ganzen nach wie vor
aber in einigen fällen nicht mehr so wie
es sein müsste
deshalb haben wir auch über fragen der
unterstützung durch den bund die
bundeswehr und der gesundheitsämter aber
auch der ordnungsämter miteinander
gesprochen wir müssen also verhindern
dass es zu einem unkontrollierten
beziehungsweise exponentiellen anstieg
weiter kommt und wir sind
in der exponentiellen phase das sieht
man an den täglichen zahlen kontrolle
über das infektionsgeschehen und über
die infektions dynamik das hat uns
geleitet bei beschlüssen die ich
ausdrücklich sehr gut finde und zwar
entsprechend unserer hotspot strategie
dass da wo 50 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner über sieben tage sind kontakt
beschränkungen eingeführt werden sowohl
im öffentlichen raum als auch im
privaten wenn es ums feiern geht des
weiteren 250
desweiteren und dass es ein neuer
schritt auch erste schritte bereits bei
35 pro 100000 einwohner
wir haben uns zu diesem prophylaktischen
zu der prophylaktischen zahl von 35
entschieden weil wir an einigen
beispielen gesehen haben wie schnell der
anstieg von 35 auf 50 dann erfolgt und
so werden also dort auch schon
erhebliche einschränkungen bei den
kontakten notwendig seien und dass wir
diese beschlüsse zu fassen konnten
das halte ich für sehr wichtig dabei ist
es auch klar gewesen das haben wir auch
beschlossen dass wir jetzt eine
bestimmte zeit abwarten wir wissen dass
die zahlen von heute im grunde das
geschehen von vor etwa zehn tagen
widerspiegeln das heißt wenn ich neue
maßnahmen einführen muss sich wieder gut
zehn tage warten um dann beurteilen zu
können ob ich die infektions dynamik
gestoppt bzw
verringert habe und wir werden dann
miteinander beraten ob neue weitere
schritte notwendig sind oder ob die
beschlossenen schritte bereits
ausgereicht haben wir haben heute in dem
vortrag des wissenschaftlers aber das
wissen wir eigentlich auch noch einmal
sehr deutlich gesehen dass die zahl der
kontakte in sehr maßgeblich ist für das
aus für die ausbreitung des infektions
geschehens und deshalb gibt es auch
einen teil des beschlusses der mich noch
nicht ganz zufrieden stellt da müssen
wir weiter arbeiten und das ist
die frage der touristischen reisen aus
den risikogebieten heraus stichwort
beherbergungs verbot wir haben darüber
sehr lange und aus den verschiedenen
facetten diskutiert das ist in der tat
auch nicht einfach umzusetzen
deshalb werden wir jetzt über die im
verlauf der herzen an den bestehenden
regeln im großen ganzen festhalten muss
ja auch stück berechenbarkeit für die
menschen geben aber dann mit dem ende
der herbstferien die letzten herbst am 8
november in bayern uns noch einmal
zusammensetzen um zu überlegen wie wir
das halten wir machen aber allerdings
sind unseren beschluss einen dringenden
aufruf von nicht notwendigen reisen
abzusehen insbesondere aus den hotspot
gebieten weil wir wissen dass natürlich
reise geschehen auch immer ein geschehen
ist was weitere infektionen verursachen
kann oder die verbreitung dann auch in
die fläche hinein noch einmal
beschleunigen kann es gibt dann in den
beschlüssen viele wichtige dinge was die
muster quarantäne verordnung anbelangt
was die frage der ordnungsämter der
unterstützung der gesundheitsämter
anbelangt was die vorbereitungen für
einen möglichen impfstoff sind über all
das gibt es sehr großen konsens
insgesamt stehen wir insofern an einem
entscheidenden punkt und das ist
natürlich auch nicht ganz einfach
abzuschätzen
reicht das was wir jetzt tun oder reicht
es nicht wir haben es sozusagen gesagt
wir beobachten dass jetzt über einen
zyklus der wirkung solcher maßnahmen das
infektionsgeschehen ist eben sehr
dynamisch geworden wir sehen in unseren
nachbarländern dass dort sehr
einschneidende maßnahmen getroffen
werden müssen und das jetzt ganz wichtig
ist und deshalb möchte ich auch nochmal
an die bürgerinnen und bürger
appellieren in dieser entscheidenden
kritischen phase des herbstes ist es
ganz ganz wichtig dass alle auch
mitmachen weiter die menschen in
deutschland haben unglaublich viel
mitgemacht und damit auch dazu
beigetragen dass wir im großen ganzen
besser dastehen als viele unserer
nachbarländer
das heißt den abstand einhalten was
getragen und die regeln
befolgen wozu jetzt im winter noch das
lüften kommt und natürlich wo immer
möglich auch die korona app nutzen weil
sie auch noch mal ein hilfsmittel ist
und dieses einhalten der regeln ist das
a und o wir müssen uns dem virus nicht
irgendwie ergeben sondern wir können
gegen dieses virus ankämpfen
und trotzdem müssen wir natürlich auch
unsererseits durch politische beschlüsse
dazu beitragen dass wir die zahl der
kontakte verringern gerade da wo die
infektionszahlen hoch sind um unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
allerdings will ich auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass selbst krankheitsverläufe
die nicht im krankenhaus enden zum teil
auch bei kona schon schwierige
krankheitsverläufe seien können wir
hören immer wieder von beispielen wo
jede familie krankheit natürlich eine
gute krankheit ist und da was uns herr
meyer hermann hört noch einmal gesagt
hat dazu hat er ja auch studien
entwickelt
es geht nicht nur um die frage des
gesundheitssystems das natürlich
zuvörderst aber auch unsere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung hängt davon
ab dass wir durch die pandemie nicht zu
schwer beeinträchtigt werden was der
gesundheit dient dient also auch der
wirtschaftlichen dem wirtschaftlichen
ablauf und sie wissen alle
wir haben einen haushalt verabschiedet
auf der bundesebene der über 250
milliarden neuverschuldung allein in
diesem jahr hat und deshalb können wir
uns auch ökonomisch eine zweite welle
wie wir sie im frühjahr hatten mit
solchen folgen nicht leisten das heißt
wir müssen alles tun um wirklich die
infektionszahlen im griff zu behalten
die kontakte nachzuvollziehen und dazu
müssen wir mit den zahlen an einigen
stellen runterkommen das waren die
beschlüsse wir haben weiter zu arbeiten
aber wir sind dazu auch gewählt
ich glaube es war tatsächlich gut und
richtig dass wir heute ja wieder im
kanzleramt zusammengekommen sind und
dass wir direkt miteinander beraten
konnten sie haben das erlebt das waren
lange beratungen und mitunter auch
kontrovers geführte es ist so es gibt
eben einfach auch die unterschiedlichen
problemen druck jeweils aufgrund der
infektionszahlen in den bundesländern
aber letztendlich war natürlich allen
bewusst dass wir tatsächlich in einer
besorgniserregenden situation sind das
muss man in aller klarheit sagen es
steht jetzt viel auf dem spiel
wir haben im letzten halben jahr viel
zusammen erreicht wir haben viel
zusammen erreicht weil wir sehr schnell
und sehr entschlossen auch eingegriffen
haben die infektionszahlen sind
kontinuierlich nach unten gegangen in
richtung sommer frau merkel darauf
hingewiesen natürlich hat uns die
jahreszeit auch in die hände gespielt
wir haben jetzt wieder die steigenden
zahlen und haben den winter vor uns und
wir wissen insofern alle miteinander
dass wir was zu tun haben und es ist in
den bundesländern ja auch schon viel
entschieden worden an maßnahmen immer
wieder auch in den letzten wochen wurde
nachgeschärft wurde nachjustiert je nach
infektionsverlauf also insofern hatten
wir heute schon eine gute grundlage um
zu sehen was können wir jetzt noch
gemeinsam darüber hinaus verabreden ich
glaube von besonderer bedeutung ist dass
wir uns tatsächlich gerade die bereiche
vorgenommen haben in denen wir keine
kontrollierten und kontrollierbaren
verfahren haben wir haben am
arbeitsplatz wir haben im öpnv wir haben
an der schule wir haben in der
gastronomie in der speisegastronomie wie
im einzelhandel wir haben viele bereiche
des öffentlichen lebens wo wir sehen
dass die regeln die wir miteinander
beschlossen haben gut umgesetzt werden
dass sie akzeptiert werden dass sie
mitgetragen werden von den bürgerinnen
und bürgern und dass sie auch gut
kontrollierbar sind das muss man auch
sagen dass es also ein erfolgreicher weg
es in diesen bereichen
wir haben andere bereiche geben eher im
privaten raum wo wir sehen dass einige
wenige leider es ist ja nicht die
mehrheit einige wenige aber diese regel
nicht 8
und damit viele andere gefährden und wir
haben uns genau diese punkte vorgenommen
wir haben uns noch einmal vorgenommen
das zusammenkommen im öffentlichen raum
dass die gruppen bilden im öffentlichen
raum alkoholausschank wir haben uns das
thema der privaten feiern vorgenommen
auch kleinere private feiern und
insofern ist es schon heute ein
wichtiger schritt nach vorne gewesen
dass wir genau in diesen bereichen auch
wirklich zur einschränkung gekommen sind
dass es je nach incidents die 35 oder
die 50er inzidenz in einer schrittfolge
eben auch eine sperrstunde empfohlen
wird oder auch auf jeden fall umgesetzt
werden soll dass der mund nasenschutz
das maske tragen weiter ausgeweitet
werden kann oder je nachdem nachhören
bei höheren infektionszahlen auch
ausgeweitet werden soll im öffentlichen
raum auch das sind glaube ich wichtige
schritte und vor allen dingen auch das
problembewusstsein nochmal schärfen für
alle beteiligten sich an der stelle das
gibt es macht auch keinen unterschied
zwischen jung und alt was es für
probleme mit sich bringen kann wenn man
regeln auch regeln in kleineren
zusammenkünften im privaten raum bei
privaten feiern bei geburtstagen bei was
weiß ich nich jubiläen nicht achtet
irgendwann geht man aus dieser feier
wieder raus und man fährt mit dem öpnv
man geht zum arbeitsplatz man trifft
andere familienmitglieder man geht zum
sport und man trägt infektionen weiter
und insofern war uns das wichtig gerade
auch in diesem bereich zu sagen wir
müssen wieder wie zum anfang wie zum
anfang auch der pandemie als wir die
ersten einschränkenden maßnahmen
beschlossen haben wieder deutlich machen
wir müssen diese größere gruppenbildung
auf jeden fall vermeiden
also insofern glaube ich waren das heute
wichtige schritte nach vorne
ich will aus berliner sicht auch noch
mal oder vielleicht auch aus sicht der
stadtstaaten hinzufügen wir haben schon
will ich sagen alles aber doch sehr viel
von den dingen die wir heute
festgehalten haben auch in berlin
beschlossen
aber es ist ganz klar das muss auch
umgesetzt und es muss auch kontrolliert
werden und dass die botschaft neben dem
appell dass jeder sich wieder bewusst
machen soll das ja auch
antwort und auch eigenverantwortung hat
und diese jetzt wahrnehmen welche an der
stelle hier auch ganz klar sagen wir
werden diese kontrollpflichten auch sehr
ernst nimmt und wir werden sehr genau
hingucken wie werden unsere regeln
umgesetzt
wir werden sie umgesetzt in der
gastronomie wir werden sie umgesetzt im
öffentlichen raum und soweit es eben
möglich ist auch im privaten raum bei
privaten feiern
ich weiß dass das schwierig ist aber es
ist jetzt wirklich eine entscheidende
phase
wenn wir weiter gehende tief
einschneidenden maßnahmen vermeiden
wollen wenn wir erhebliche konsequenz
und nicht nur für die wirtschaft sondern
für unser zusammenleben wenn wir große
soziale konsequenzen vermeiden wollen
wenn kinder nicht wie was ja erlebt
haben wie es sein muss zur schule gehen
können und und und wenn wir all das
vermeiden wollen
kommt es jetzt wahrscheinlich genau auf
die nächsten wochen an auf dieser herbst
wochen in denen wir uns befinden ob
unsere maßnahmen entsprechend angenommen
werden ob sie umgesetzt werden von uns
allen
aber ob sie eben von allem auch mit der
entsprechenden eigenverantwortung
mitgetragen werden
wir sind heute schon einen deutlichen
schritt vorangekommen für das ganze land
aber ob das reicht ist meiner meinung
nach offen
wir sind dem zweiten lok dann eigentlich
viel näher als wir das wahrhaben wollen
wenn wir die entwicklung anschauen heute
auch den bericht des experten die die
wenn die zahlen sich gerade entwickeln
welcher dynamik wenn wir sehen was um
uns herum passiert dann ist das wirklich
höchste zeit vielleicht gar nicht mehr
fünf vor zwölf sondern schlag 12 um
jetzt die weichen richtig zu stellen
insofern war der termin heute ist gerade
im vorfeld diskussion braucht es war
zwingend notwendig und es war auch
wichtig zu reden
auch wenn manches etwas zäh war denn
eines ist klar wir müssen nochmal das
bewusstsein schaffen was ist eigentlich
geht sollte ein zweiter lockdown kommen
würdest für deutschland erhebliche
schädigungen haben wird den wohlstand
unseres landes fundamental gefährden
und für die nächste generation für
schulen für schüler für kinder in kitas
dauerhafte schäden verursachen
deswegen ist es dringend nötig das was
wir jetzt machen nicht nur stabilisieren
sondern was mich freut wenn man da immer
umzusetzen und zwar gemeinschaftlich das
was so entschlossen wie es geht
wir haben das sprunghafte wachstum und
es wächst auch wieder in die
krankenhäuser corona belehrt uns gerade
eindrücklich dass altes diskussionen der
vergangenen woche es handele sich um
eine normale grippe es sei nicht so
gefährlich
es würde keine auswirkungen haben im
rest von europa sich wieder leider als
das erweist wie es vorher war
cola bleibt komplett gleich gefährlich
und die zweite welle ist auch absolut da
also deswegen arzt auch keinen sinn sich
das schön so wie im gegenteil die lage
ist ein bisschen gefährlicher fast als
im frühjahr
warum weil er im frühjahr die hoffnung
auf sommer hatten und jetzt haben wir
die herausforderung des wetters der
winter kommt
das heißt das macht doch für all die
ganzen fragen aus wieden ist eher
schwierig
deswegen glaube ich ist es wichtig heute
die weichenstellung vorzunehmen gut und
positiv ist auf jeden fall
es gibt mehr einheitlichkeit heute gut
und positiv ist es gibt auch so kann man
glaube ich verständlich geregelt für
alle das ist das wichtige dabei und was
ich jetzt auch selbst sei als minister
wir sind vom freistaat bayern
ich finde auch die philosophie dahinter
steht richtig die philosophie mehr maske
weniger alkohol und deutlich weniger
feiern das ist der dreiklang an
instrumenten die wir letztlich haben
wenn man das nationale
infektionsgeschehen bei uns sieht und
die erfahrungen der vergangenen monate
auch revue passieren lässt und sie auch
umsetzen wenn wir sind nicht die
bestimmten professionellen
veranstaltungen das ist der ganze
private sektor sind brauchen wir
dringend mehr maske und auch mehr masten
pflicht die wir haben werden wir
brauchen auch die entsprechenden alkohol
einschränkungen
ob sperrstunde alkoholverkauf alkohol
nutzung dann zu entsprechenden seiten
und auch eine eine deutliche
einschränkung der feiern
es ist eigentlich immer ärgerlich das
ist eine sich nur um sehr wenige handelt
die dafür verantwortlich sind
aber da muss man jetzt einfach ein
signal setzen
es geht hier übrigens bei der ganzen
frage nicht um die frage von loyalität
gegenüber den start von ordnungs
gläubigkeit und setzt der staat sich
durch das keine frage von loyalität
sondern schweigen von solidarität im
grunde genommen geht es darum
risikogruppen die ältere generation zu
schützen
und dieses schutz versprechen muss eine
generation gemeinschaftlich leisten und
das sind glaube ich ist es so wichtig
dass wir das heute schaffen de facto ist
jetzt eine gute krone ab also was sowohl
von der sie als auch von der idee ist es
und zwar eine eine einfache coronado wir
haben in europa verschiedene corona
ampeln musik zahlen miteinander
kombiniert werden wo kein mensch durch
blickt also infektionszahlen mit
irgendwelchen anderen verrechnungen wird
es dann gemacht wo dass er eine
mathematische formel bei uns ist ganz
einfach
37 50 das ist eine ganz einfache klare
regelung welche maßnahmen und gelten bis
35 die normalen abstand zu distanzieren
ab 35 die vorsichtsregeln die dann schon
getroffen werden müssen mit den
einschränkungen 150 dann die sehr sehr
konsequenten ob das reicht werden wir
sehen es liegt vieles auf wiedervorlage
wenn ich die nächsten zehn tage sehen
wenn es nicht wirkt wann wird man über
reden müssen ob man noch nach schaffen
kann und entsprechend ergänzt wir hoffen
jetzt mal dass es wirkt wenn es überall
einheitlich angewendet wird wenn es
übrigens überall einheitlich angewandt
wird dann stellen sich auch manche
fragen innerhalb des reisens weniger in
deutschland
denn wenn jeder das gleiche konzept
schutzkonzept hat dann können auch diese
fragen entspannter oder auf einer
anderen basis diskutiert werden
zusammenfassend gesagt es hat sich
gelohnt der termin zusammen darf aber
ich teile das was beide sagt nicht
kannst du der bürgermeister müller wenn
man es so denn die nachrichten des
abends zu liest was man in frankreich
beschließt was gestern holland
geschlossen wurde
da kann man sehen was passieren kann
wenn wir uns dem thema stellen
ich kann nur an jeden appellieren ist
bitter ernst zu nehmendes gilt als
verantwortungsträger auch an die
bevölkerung so viele halten sich so
großartig daran
und die müssen wir auch mitnehmen und
weiter engagiert dabei betreuen aber
auch mithelfen dass diejenigen die noch
skeptisch sind sich auf dem weg
mitmachen und mit begeben
es steht unglaublich viel auf dem spiel
und wir brauchen einen langen atem aber
es handelt sich ja nicht um ähnlich es
handelt sich nicht um ewig und die folge
wenn wir jetzt fehler machen
die sind viel größer als die
herausforderungen und die belastungen
wenn wir uns alle ein stück weit mühe
geben es braucht eigentlich nicht so
viel
und diese herausforderung zu bestehen
und schlimmere folgen abzuwenden
ich glaube mit dem heutigen beitrag
haben einen regelwerk auf den weg
gebracht um zu den ganzen meldungen die
zwischen den gelaufen sind wie wir dann
so alles gelesen haben was solle
stattfindet kann er sei ja es gab ein
paar stellen wo sich da ein oder oder
die ein oder andere sich mehr gewünscht
hätte
aber am ende spielen wir dann
hoffentlich doch alle in einem team
nämlich in dem team umsicht und vorsicht
und das hat sich heute durchgesetzt
also es hat heute nicht am ende sich
durchgesetzt die idee dies sei alles gar
nicht so schlimm
und er könne das doch irgendwie auch
anders bewältigen und mehr so lizenz
verunsichern sondern das team umsicht
und vorsicht das hat sich am ende
durchsetzt und unglaublich war das ein
gewinn pro werktag der aber noch nicht
der letzte gewesen ist in das büro
wir kommen zu ihren fragen die erste vom
herrn rinke von reuters herzlichen dank
ich hätte eine frage zu der akzeptanz
die haben sie ja eigentlich alle drei
betont nun gibt es ausgerechnet in dem
bereich wo es am wenigsten kommt
akzeptanz in den letzten tagen gibt
nämlich bei der beherbergung anscheinend
keine gemeinsame regel ist das nicht ein
kleiner widerspruch und also wieder eine
spezial frage an sie noch hinterher
bußgelder spielen jetzt eigentlich keine
rolle die hatten sie vorgeschlagen
halten sie das nicht mehr für notwendig
oder war das nicht durchsetzbar da
kannst du ja was dazu wenn ja was wenn
ich sagen kann ja die das sogenannte
beherbergungs verbot hat fragen
aufgeworfen
das schwierige ist wir sind uns
vollkommen einig bund und länder fordern
eindringlich alle bürgerinnen und bürger
auch nicht erforderliche innerdeutsche
reisen in gebiete und aus gebieten
heraus welche die grenze von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
innerhalb der letzten sieben tage
übersteigen zu vermeiden
da gibt es keine frage dran es ist
allgemein akzeptiert wenn das nachher
operationalisieren werden soll
wie sieht das genau aus dann stellt sich
das als schwieriger heraus als dieser
satz klingt und darüber muss weiter
geredet werden das hat sich erwiesen
sowohl was die länder anbelangt die
sozusagen sehr viele touristische
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten haben aber
auch was die anbelangt die jetzt selber
risikogebiet sind und das solange das
einen landkreis war hat sich das noch
relativ einfach dargestellt aber wenn
das natürlich dann sehr sehr viele
gebiete sind dann wird das insgesamt
schwieriger ich finde
trotzdem jetzt vernünftig dass wir
gesagt haben wir warten die phase dieser
herbst fehlen jetzt mal ab und werden
dann darauf zurückkommen aber da ist
noch viel arbeit zu leisten und es ist
unbestritten dass natürlich reiseverkehr
auch immer wieder viele kontakte mit
sich bringt und das was mich einfach
umtreibt ist das haben wir heute an den
simulationen auch sehr gut gelegen sehen
dass eben die tage zählen und wann ich
welche maßnahme mache das ist nicht egal
ob ich etwas um sieben tagen zehn tagen
oder heute war gestern macher und so
muss man gucken dass wir eben einfach
die freiheit wiedererlangen dort wo sie
uns ein stück verloren gegangen ist auch
durch unterstützung der ämter aber eben
auch durch kontakt beschränkungen und
ich persönlich bin einfach der meinung
dass wir die mittel in der hand haben um
diesen virus uns entgegen zu stemmen und
auch mit ihm umzugehen und das ist uns
ja auch gut gelungen von märz an
und jetzt mag eine maßnahme auch eine
begrenzte akzeptanz haben dann muss man
natürlich gucken dass sie eine bessere
bekommt aber sie ist deshalb als solche
das ich sozusagen unnötige reisen
vermeide noch nicht falsch das muss man
auch den menschen sagen und deshalb
treibt mich einfach um das ist dann in
der diskussion auch deutlich geworden
wir haben es hier mit einer
riesenherausforderung und hoffentlich
einer jahrhundert herausforderung zu tun
die ganz viel nach sich ziehen kann
gesundheit von menschen die frage wie
viele menschen sterben sie sehen das an
den statistiken der länder über die welt
verteilt das kann man so und das kann
man so machen und die frage was wird aus
unserer wirtschaft und damit aus unserem
wohlstand und damit auch aus der jugend
die er noch viel mehr lebensjahre vor
sich hat und gerade die jugend ist es an
die wir jetzt auch appellieren müssen
lieber heute auf den paketen und feiern
und partys zu verzichten um morgen und
übermorgen gut leben zu können
da hängt sehr viel dran und wir haben ja
an den ereignissen des frühjahrs gesehen
wie das unsere haushalte
durcheinanderwirbelt und wir haben wir
sind ein leistungsfähiges land aber wir
haben auch keine unbegrenzten
möglichkeiten
und deshalb muss noch mit unseren
ressourcen vorsichtig umgehen
eine gemeinschaft und auch ein start auf
kein zahnloser tiger sein
das heißt wenn er vorgaben macht und
alle machen mit ist kein problem wenn
sie sich einigen älteren halten müsse
auch zeigen dass im ganzen
deswegen ist natürlich bußgeld ist
absolut wichtig wir haben sie über das
teilweise der bayern und berlin die
gleichen bußgeld dafür lasten verweigert
das ist ja auch dieselbe einstellung zum
thema mars gewendet das so sagen darf
was sehr positiv an der stelle
und deswegen sind wir da sehr für den
bereich aber es gibt den einen oder
andern hartnäckig in sanktions noch
nicht überzeugt oder nicht so
überzeugten
es kommt man heute schaffen aber bleibt
dabei ohne eine bußgeld sanktion hat das
ganze keinen sinn
wir haben ja für quarantäne fragen das
ganze und deswegen also es bleibt auf
jeden fall zu tage sollten
und in den meisten bundesländern wird zu
bizarr umgesetzt so mit der zahl der
erwachsenen studien wird die zahlen
steigen also ist ja sogar einmal alles
anschaut dann sind doch die bundesländer
die vor zehn tagen das thema nicht so
bedrohlich empfunden haben freut bei
zahlen die kurz davor stehen zu springen
alles vom sprung und 35 ist das fast
schon 50 muss man sagen es geht dann
ganz schnell mittlerweile ein bisschen
ändern sich die dinge in italien und
nicht in wochen und deswegen glaube ich
würden wir noch manches was jetzt für
den einer ganz schwierig und schlimmes
werden wir dann wieder schneller
beschließen die realität holt uns
schnell einig wenn es halt besser man
ist vor der welle
man läuft der welle nicht hinterher frau
marge von rbb eine frage bitte
gerade in der vergangenen woche ist es
ja auch sehr öffentlich diskutiert
worden gerade sie herr müller und auch
sie herr söder hat es ja auch sehr viele
konflikte gegeben und das ist ja
eigentlich auch eine akzeptanz von makam
auch kontraproduktiv ist dieser umgang
miteinander heute auch thematisiert
worden
ja ich glaube unsere beschlüsse machen
deutlich dass wir ja herzhaften aber
auch sehr konstruktiven umgang
miteinander gepflegt haben und ich
glaube also da und ich habe es ja in
beide auch deutlich gemacht es gibt doch
vieles wo wir überhaupt kein problem
haben auch deutlich zu sagen wie es
stehen vor den gleichen
herausforderungen wir versuchen auch im
gleichen weg zu gehen
wir versuchen ihnen gemeinsam umzusetzen
dass es nun zwischen einem großen
flächenland mit europäischen nachbarn
und einem stadtstaat auch
unterschiedlichen problemdruck gibt auf
denen wir individuell reagieren müssen
ich glaube auch das ist ganz normal und
insofern wenn ich das zum beherbergungs
verbot vielleicht auch noch mal sagen
darf bundeskanzlerin hat ja eben schon
deutlich gemacht wir wollen einfach
jetzt auch sehen oder die länder die das
jetzt umgesetzt haben eingeführt haben
wollen auch damit erfahrungen sammeln
wollen sehen wie es funktioniert wir
gemeinsam wollen sie in die andere
maßnahmen wirken und was für
auswirkungen das dann wiederum auf
dieses beherbergungs verbot hat aber ich
habe natürlich nun für berlin für die
stadt auch deutlich gemacht dass ich da
auch ein umsetzungsproblem sehe und das
sind ist ja nicht nur die beziehung
zwischen berlin und brandenburg der
pendler und wie viele berliner dürfe
nirgendwo hin reisen
es kommen ja auch viele menschen in die
stadt und bringen möglicherweise
infektionen mit
wenn ich an den ganzen politikbetrieb
denke wenn ich an den ganzen
kulturbetrieb denke und und und und mir
wäre dann die konsequenz und es in aller
klarheit zu sagen die stadt waren ihrer
geschichte mehrfach abgeriegelt das ist
für mich keine erneute optionen und
insofern muss man da auch mit 100 zu
vernünftigen verabredung kommen nicht
nur das problem erkennen nicht nur eine
maßnahme beschließen sondern auch
gemeinsam sehen wie man die umsetzung
tragen kann und das ist nicht nur für
berlin das ist für die großstädte eben
nicht so einfach das muss man sagen alle
bis heute von vom ganzen welt
miteinander glaube ich sehr vernünftig
funktioniert das kann man kann man sagen
wahrheit von einem gemeinschaftlichen
bewusstsein getragen
und bei diesem einen thema der glaube
ist immer auch ein stück weitergekommen
wenn ich das sagen darf aber noch nicht
endgültig
ja dann muss man doch auch ganz einfach
sehen wir stehen doch auch alle
herausforderungen die wir vom halben
jahr oder vor sieben acht monaten noch
nicht gekannt haben und dass wir nun
alle hier im saal einziehen und mit der
gleichen meinung an die sache rangehen
das ist ja relativ unwahrscheinlich und
dass man sich da zusammen rauchen muss
dass man aus der diskussion auch was
lernt und dass die auch sehr ehrlich ist
weil es um was geht das ist finde ich
eher ein gutes zeichen dass sie das
immer gleich alle informatorischen
mitbekommen dass gehört offensichtlich
zu der modernen welt dazu aber deshalb
können wir ja trotzdem nicht darauf
verzichten um den richtigen weg auch
wirklich zu bringen und das finde ich
auch verständlich bei so einer situation
muss bauer bild frau bundeskanzlerin von
ihnen es jetzt aus der heutigen sitzung
ein satz überliefert
der besagt oder sie sollen gesagt haben
diese maßnahmen sind nicht hart genug um
das unheil abzuwenden welches unheil
meinen sie damit woran denken sie da
wenn sie das so im kopf haben und es ist
ja kein geheimnis dass sie sich auf
jeden fall schärfere maßnahmen gewünscht
hätten
man merkt ihm jetzt auch anders wie
vielleicht nicht so 100 prozent
glücklich sind mit dem ausgang wie
frustriert sind sie jetzt nach diesen
fünf vertragen und möglicherweise doch
nicht ebenso harten maßnahmen wie sich
gewünscht haben nein ich habe ja gesagt
womit ich zufrieden bin und da gibt es
wichtige teile mit dem bin ich absolut
zufrieden und wenn man auch die kontakt
beschränkungen geht die wir eingeführt
haben für 35 nicht erst bei 50 sondern
schon bei 35 und dann habe ich dort an
welcher stelle ich nicht zufrieden bin
und wo man weiter arbeiten muss und wenn
sie mich fragen was ist das was mich
beunruhigt dann ist das der
exponentielle anstieg und den müssen wir
stoppen
sonst wird es in kein gutes ende führen
das sehen wir an allen ecken und ende
brauche ich gar nicht nach deutschland
zu gucken da bloß in die nachbarschaft
zu gucken
das ist der punkt und diesen
exponentiellen
stieg müssen der stopp je schneller umso
besser und deshalb wer das vollkommen
abgeschlossene paket auch bezüglich wie
ihre mama ist mit den reifen besser
gewesen noch aber trotzdem war es eine
ganz wichtige sitzung wo auch sehr sehr
gutes und wichtiges alt wird herfried
sie deutsche frau bundeskanzlerin ich
wollte noch mal nach ihrer mathematik
fragen und zwar sie sagten ja selber das
geschehen was wir heute sehen mit den
über 5000 infektionen ist einiges
geschehen von vor zehn tagen also das
infektionsgeschehen und jetzt
beschließen sie maßnahmen vor deren
wirkung wäre ja auch frühestens in zehn
tagen sehen kann also sind wir
eigentlich nicht angesichts der tatsache
dass das infektionsgeschehen sich weiter
verschlechtert hat und zwar ziemlich
deutlich auch nach ihrer sitzung am 29
nicht offensichtlich der entwicklung
jetzt schon deutlich hinterher
gemessen an dem als wenn man jetzt mal
sagen würde
der zustand im sommer anfang des sommers
war für uns der den wir gut händeln
können dann sind wir über den sommer in
eine situation gekommen die sich jetzt
noch verstärkt hat wo wir mit unserer
maßnahmen dem infektionsgeschehen
hinterher sind wir haben heute
gesundheits einfach die nicht mehr 100
prozent die kontrolle haben und deshalb
hat er soeben gesagt richtigerweise wir
müssen vor die welle kommt das ist
wichtig dass wir sozusagen wieder ein
denn und deshalb ist die frage reicht
das was wir heute gemacht haben
eine zentrale frage und es kann sein
dass wir in zehn oder zwölf tagen sagen
müssen wir haben diesen anstieg nicht so
gestoppt wie wir das wollten
das kann auch keiner ganz genau wissen
wie das alles wirkt keiner kann sagen
wie wichtig ist der reise faktor wie
wichtig ist die beschränkung die ja sehr
hart ist wenn ich über
50 hunderttausend bin dann darf ich zu
hause nur zwei haus stände maximal zehn
personen noch haben oder 10 im
öffentlichen raum bei feierlichkeiten
das sind ja schon deutliche
einschränkungen alkoholverbot
sperrstunde
das sind dinge die sind jetzt zum teil
ja hier in berlin zum beispiel schon in
kraft aber deren wirkung sehen wir noch
nicht aber es kann uns auch im
augenblick keiner sagen wir können
abstrakt sagen wenn der 50 prozent der
kontakte einschränken würden dann würden
wir eine beruhigung haben das haben wir
heute modell mäßig gesehen
aber was sind 50 prozent der kontakte
wer will das jetzt genau ausrechnen
das heißt in gewisser weise müssen wir
auch immer wieder einen versuch
unternehmen und dann nach steuern das
wird jetzt immer so bleiben
ob das heute eben genug war oder nicht
das wird sich sehen werden wir sehen und
deshalb ist meine unruhe mit dem
heutigen tag noch nicht weg aber es war
trotzdem ein absolut wichtiger schritt
die ende gegangen herr meier dpa im
anschluss dieses frau bundeskanzlerin
wenn sich die maßnahmen tatsächlich für
eine besserung eignen was muss dann
geschehen müssen die sanktionen noch
schafe werden und die kontrollen noch
härter und umgekehrt
wir reden von kontakt beschränkungen es
geht immer um kontakte vor haben wir die
sie haben wir die und da gibt es
natürlich noch viele möglichkeiten dann
auch härtere maßnahmen zu ergreifen das
ist klar wir haben noch mal deutlich
gemacht was wollen wir erreichen wir
wollen die wirtschaftskreisläufe
möglichst da wo es geht sich entwickeln
lassen wir wollen kita und schule sind
für uns ganz wichtig und bei anderen
kontakten muss man eben immer wieder
gucken sind sie zu viel oder oder reicht
es schon was wir an beschränkungen
einführen und ich sag mal so es gibt
nachbarländer in einigen
großstädten in frankreich ist heute sind
noch härtere maßnahmen gewarnt worden
von dem französischen präsidenten und
auch in den niederlanden sind jetzt sehr
harte maßnahmen angeführt worden
und jetzt muss man gucken ist die
sperrstunde darüber haben wir auch
gesprochen 23 uhr nun genau die richtige
muss man sie bei 22 uhr machen
sie sind die verhaltensweisen so das
kann dann muss dann noch geschafft
werden
ja natürlich das geht einher ich hab das
ja gerade gesagt es gibt jeden satz der
schlüssel zu den kontakten zu den
einschränkungen der kontakte zwei
wichtige dinge die auch in berlin auf
der tagesordnung
das eine ist das entsprechende
kontrollieren und das zweite ist das
durchbrechen als nachvollziehen und
durchbrechen der infektionsketten und
insofern ist dafür eben auch der
erheblich größere personaleinsatz
notwendig das ist ganz klar und dem
werden wir mit aller ernsthaftigkeit
auch nachgehen also insofern kommt
beschluss einschränkung und kontrolle
müssen einhergehen
aber ich möchte es tatsächlich doch noch
mal grundsätzlich einen ordnern ich weiß
was wir vielen menschen zumuten
sagen wir ich weiß was sich auch in der
metropole berlin fielen zumute in der
gastronomie im kulturbetrieb vielen
jungen menschen zumute aber was können
wir eigentlich noch tun um jedem
begreiflich zu machen wir sind in einer
weltweiten krise und in einer weltweiten
krise gibt es einschränkungen
und die könnte erheblich dramatischer
sein als das was wir bisher miteinander
beschlossen haben
wir mussten in den letzten monaten auch
nicht so erheblich einschränken weil wir
gute zahlen hatten
aber es muss doch jedem jetzt mal
bewusst sein und das ist keine
kaffeesatzleserei das ist nicht
böswillig und das ist kein aberglaube
der hier vorgetragen wird sondern man
sieht die zahlen
wir haben zu beginn der pandemie gesehen
was in italienischen und französischen
krankenhäusern loses ich werde das bild
nicht vergessen die massengrab auf einer
insel vor manhattan aus gefahr
ausgehoben wurde
das haben wir alles gesehen und wenn wir
das vermeiden wollen solche bilder
wieder zusehen muss jedem bewusst sein
ja in einer krise gibt es anstrengung
und wir gemeinsam müssen jetzt durch
diese anstrengung durch wir müssen
gemeinsam diese krise bewältigen darum
geht es und deswegen auch wenn es für
viele eine einschränkung ist nicht mehr
bis 24 uhr die kneipe offen zu haben
sondern nur noch bis 23 uhr und wer weiß
vielleicht in zwei oder drei wochen nur
noch bis 20 uhr
ja es ist eine einschränkung aber die
gesundheit steht im vordergrund und ich
glaube dann ist so ein weg auch mit zu
tragen die die einschränkungen die es
geht sind natürlich tief greifender
freien liberalen gesellschaft aber es
entstehen der schutzgüter dagegen also
eine stunde weniger alkohol kann ja wohl
nicht ernsthaft wichtiger sein als am
ende die frage ob wir wieder drei
systeme wie in anderen ländern
diskutieren wollen wenn wir das sehen
was in den krankenhäusern los ist dann
in europa und stellen wir fest dass die
debatte die wir in deutschland geführt
haben jetzt einige wochen und monate
das sei alles nicht so schlimm das würde
gar nicht in die krankenhaus gekommen
das ist zumindest aus europäischer
widerlegt und in deutschland deutete
sich an dass entscheidend ist aber dass
wir nicht darauf warten dürfen bis man
die krankenhäuser wieder voll hat wenn
die krankenhäuser voll sind ist es zu
spät weil es in der tat
es wurde vorhin angesprochen diese zwei
wochen verzögerung gibt wir sind ja
jetzt in der situation dass wir die
nächsten zwei wochen aus dem was jetzt
passiert noch da keine auswirkungen
spüren dass die zahlen werden jetzt
erstmal deutlich steigen
wir können es den zehn tagen zwei wochen
erkennen ob es etwas wirkt oder nicht
der moment in bayern die situation dass
wir an einstellen stabiler wirken sagt
sietz immer so wohnen ohne in anspruch
zu haben weil wir sehr schnell reagiert
haben
die landeshauptstadt münchen bei uns und
wenn wir das konzept gemacht es ist
jetzt übernommenen vieler dinge die
jetzt in dem konzept haben wir jetzt
schon vor einigen tagen gemacht da gibt
es keine garantie dass das wirkt ja aber
es ist schon die einzigen konzepte die
wir haben und der instrumentenkasten ist
klar beschrieben
kontakte verfolgen kann man nur wenn man
kontakte dann vielleicht geschwenkt und
reduziert der alkohol hat ihm seine
enthemmende wirkung wenn sie 90 dann
näher kommen also muss ich schauen dass
ich da ein steuerungsinstrument
reinbekommen und wir haben festgestellt
dass die infektion bei normalen
veranstaltungen sowie zb insgesamt
wahrscheinlich nicht auf null zu fahren
sind aber reduziert werden weil wir
maske und andere möglichkeiten haben
aber dort wo keine maske mehr
stattfindet im privaten sektor private
feier
die leute gehen dann raus am vor in
einem öffentlichen bereich sich mit
maske auch bewegt und dann kommen sie in
den privaten bereich legen sie ab und
dort entstehen zum teil sprunghafte
ansteckungen und dies gilt es jetzt
einfach zu kanalisieren und einzudämmen
das ist ja die strategie der
gegenteilige strategie wird durchlaufen
lassen
das nimmt man der gemeinde durch solchen
mit erheblichen ethischen auswirkungen
die wir nicht wollen deswegen dann wird
die nächsten zehn tage versuchen diese
maßnahmen alle umzusetzen
jeder geht jetzt zurück dann in sein
land und wird versuchen das wort
umzusetzen oder zu beschleunigen wenn
man auch kabinett in bayern wo wir noch
mal genau danach schaffen an einigen
stellen bzw
das noch weiterfahren kann und dann
heißt es tatsächlich die
gesundheitsämter zu stärken die ganzen
bereich auf den weg zu bringen die
masten pflicht zu organisieren bzw auch
einzuhalten und zu überwachen und auch
zu gestalten und dann bin ich eigentlich
schon optimal funktioniert also wir
haben den corona wir es ja schon
getrotzt sehr erfolgreich ich dachte ich
deswegen sagen weil wir am stärksten
betroffen waren unter anderem
verständnis wenn manch einer gesagt den
letzten wochen macht der markus söder
war immer so eine so ein so großes thema
dass jetzt genauer lebt was passiert
wenn es außer kontrolle geraten kann
es gibt es so schnell produkt das aus
gar nicht so schnell
bis die entwicklung aus der hand gottes
kostet sehr viel kraft wieder die
kontrolle über die entwicklung zu
bekommen und deswegen auch bin ich
einfach nachdenklich heute es ist jetzt
alles gut ich hoffe nicht dass es ein
paar tage zu spät ist ja noch glaube ich
könnte anders könnte es reichen
aber wenn es nicht reicht gibt es auch
gar keine alternative dazu als dann halt
nach zu schaffen aufgeben gilt nicht
sondern wenn muss man sich dieser
herausforderung stellen
ich kann den beiden nur zustimmen das
ist die bewährungsprobe die große
unserer generation jetzt hier und die
ganze welt ist davon betroffen wenn wir
die karten sieht von vom lka um uns
herum
dann ist deutschland im moment noch
siebter farblicher hebt sich ab alles
anders rot und dunkelrot und zu glauben
dass das kein eintrag hat wir haben ja
einzelne bundesländer die haben bislang
ganz wenig wenn es sich bei 1 andere die
gekommen auch aus anderen ländern den
eintrag und zu glauben dass das was sie
der niederlande passiert in frankreich
passiert keinen einfluss auf ein land
ein kontinent mit offenen grenzen hat
ist im besten sinne sehr sehr
optimistisch und deswegen müssen wir
unseren beitrag einfach leisten und das
größte land in europa muss stabil
bleiben muss dann muss da auch versuchen
die herausforderung zu trotzen und ich
glaube tatsächlich dass das jederzeit
machbar ist und zwar jetzt mit weniger
aufwand als später mit viel viel
größeren und schmerzhaften danke dem
podium danke der presse einladen
soweit also die pressekonferenz von
angela merkel dem regierenden
bürgermeister müller und bayerns
ministerpräsident
zu den gerade beschlossenen corona
maßnahmen von bund und ländern ich fasse
das noch einmal ganz kurz zusammen es
wird also wieder kontakt beschränkungen
geben in gebieten wo es erhöhte
infektionszahlen gibt das gibt einmal
die zahl 35 neuinfektionen auf 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen dort gibt es
dann sachen die sperrstunden eine masken
pflicht im öffentlichen raum wo menschen
länger und dichter zusammen kommen
private feiern sollen beschränkt werden
auf 25 menschen im öffentlichen raum und
15 im privaten raum einige wollen das
aber nur als empfehlung formulieren da
gibt es also auch schon uneinigkeiten
zwischen bund und ländern
und dann gibt es die neue zahl von 50
neuinfektionen von 100 pro 100000
einwohner über sieben tage dort gibt es
dann schärfere maßnahmen eine massen
pflicht im öffentlichen raum nur noch
zehn personen dürfen sich treffen die
gastronomie wird ab 23 uhr schließen das
wird kein alkohol mehr geben
bei feiern in der öffentlichkeit dürfen
zehn menschen zusammen kommen im
privaten raum maximal zehn leute aus
zwei veranstaltungen und veranstaltungen
werden haushalten veranstaltungen werden
auf 100 teilnehmer beschränkt das ganze
also wieder sehr kleinteilig und
dezidiert und darüber spreche ich jetzt
noch mal mit dem spd gesundheitsexperten
karl lauterbach der mir in seiner
wohnung in köln zugeschaltet ist herr
lauterbach jetzt haben wir gerade gehört
wie sich bundeskanzlerin merkel und auch
herr söder sehr sehr besorgt geäußert
haben
sie sprechen dort wirklich von einer
schwierigen lage das hören wir jetzt
aber natürlich schon ein halbes jahr
viele menschen sind müde das sehen wir
auch in den kommentaren können sie das
nachvollziehen dass auch menschen sagen
es reicht mir jetzt mal diese schlimmen
angedrohten szenarien sind nicht
eingetroffen können wir nicht mal wieder
ein bisschen locker machen also die
maßnahmen sind zunächst einmal gute
maßnahmen und das jetzt die situation
droht aus der hand zu geraten das ist
einfach richtig also wir sind derzeit in
einem ganz wichtigen wende
bereich werden wir die kurse jetzt nicht
bekommen dann sind wir zurück zum
exponentiellen wachstums und dann würde
es hat sehr sehr gefährlich es ist mein
land ja schon gesagt wir wenn ein
anderer ex potenziellen phase sind sie
da nicht ihrer meinung wir sind also das
exponentielle wachstum fängt ja zuerst
ganz langsam an somit ist dass da mal
eine frage wie man es definiert wir sind
natürlich im exponentiellen wachstum
wieder angekommen aber es ist wie phasen
wo das noch berstein exponentielle
wachstum erst mal eine gewisse größe
erreicht das dann ist es schwer
einzufangen und wir sind dann beende
punkt darauf gesprochen dass wind in den
nächsten zwei wochen wird sich
entscheiden ob wir also einen weg gehen
können der anders ist als der weg in den
ländern um uns herum den niederlanden in
frankreich beispielsweise oder auch
england wo er schon ganz andere zustände
haben oder ob ihr den also gleichen weg
gehen müssen das entscheidet sich jetzt
angela merkel hat auch in der
pressekonferenz gerade gesagt sie ist
zufrieden mit einigen maßnahmen mit
anderen ist sie unzufrieden und sie hat
die frage gestellt reicht das
die gebe ich mal an sie weiter reicht
das ich glaube die maßnahmen die heute
beschlossen worden sind gute maßnahmen
das sind die wichtigsten maßnahmen
beschlossen worden
es wird ja sehr viel über das
beherbergungs verbot gestritten
das beherbergungs verbot ist aber
gemessen an den anderen maßnahmen
definitiv nicht die wichtigste
entscheidung
das ist die frage brauchen während er
werde das verbot ja oder nein
darüber kann man streiten da kann man
sehr unterschiedlicher meinung sagen
aber unstrittig ist da sind vergleich zu
den anderen maßnahmen und das berger
werden was beherbergungs verbot eine
geringe bedeutung hat aber wäre ja nicht
nur gewesen jetzt einfach mal zu sagen
wir kippen dass das hat ja für sehr viel
unmut gesorgt in den letzten tagen viele
menschen haben da tatsächlich
fragezeichen dahinter gemacht ob das
alles gut funktioniert ob das
tatsächlich sinnvoll ist was dort
gemacht wird wäre es nicht klüger
gewesen einfach zu sagen wenn sie jetzt
sagen dass das nicht die wichtige
maßnahme dass die länder sich
zusammengerauft hätten gesagt hätten
okay jetzt lassen was sein sollte man
machen können keine frage weil es nicht
die wichtigste maßnahme ist was auch
kippen können
aber ich blicke einfach auf das was
gelungen ist ich blicke nicht doch das
was nicht geboren ist und ich glaube
dazu
ich dass diese zweiteilung in einmal
eine incidents rate 35 pro 100000 pro
sieben tage und 50.000 pro sieben tage
das ist sehr gut dass seine klare
gabelung und die also beschränkung beim
piraten feiern auf 15 in der 15er gruppe
also in der gruppe h 35 100.000 und dann
10 ab 50 das ist aus meiner sicht
ebenfalls richtig gewählt die stärke
masken pflicht ist richtig die
sperrstunden sind richtig das
alkoholverbot wenn es notwendig wird
das sind alles die richtigen
entscheidungen und somit im großen und
ganzen bin ich mit den ergebnissen sehr
zufrieden und würde nicht auf das
schauen was nicht gelungen ist sondern
auch das schauen was gelungen ist das
und wir werden sehen wie gut es wird in
den nächsten tagen
das gab mir noch meinen kommentaren auch
die frage nach diesen tatsächlich auf
diesen incidents zahlen
da wurde kritisiert dass die willkürlich
getroffen sein gibt es dafür
irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse dass man die jetzt bei 35
und 50 liegt wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse gibt es dafür nicht das
sind in gewisser weise gläsern der werte
wie orientieren sich aber an dem was
beispielsweise die gesundheitsämter noch
nachvollziehen können und wo wir wissen
wo wir mal eine kritische grenze von
fällen überschritten wird so dass die
gesundheitsämter nicht mehr nachkommen
da ist das ungefähr also entwickelt
worden
das ist eine nützliche überschaubare und
sinnvolle einteilung der fallzahlen die
in der praxis auch schon seit ein paar
wochen ganz gut bewährt hat herr
lauterbach ich danke ihnen dass sie
heute abend uns ausgeharrt haben und
diese ersten einschränkung
einschränkungen sollte das wort so oft
gesagt heute einschränkungen
diese ersten einschätzungen von ihrer
seite zu den beschlossenen corona
einschränken und maßnahmen mit uns
geteilt haben ich bedanke mich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend
und jetzt kriegen wir einen o-ton hör
ich gerade aus der regie ich weiß
tatsächlich jetzt nichts von wem wir
lassen uns überraschen ich vermute mal
von bundeskanzlerin merkel
deshalb möchte ich auch nochmal an die
bürger
drinnen und bürger appellieren in dieser
entscheidenden kritischen phase des
herbstes ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass
alle auch mitmachen weiter die menschen
in deutschland haben unglaublich viel
mitgemacht und damit auch dazu
beigetragen dass wir im großen ganzen
besser dastehen als viele unserer
nachbarländer
das heißt den abstand einhalten maske
tragen und die regeln befolgen wozu
jetzt im winter noch das lüften kommt
und natürlich wo immer möglich auch die
korona app nutzen weil sie auch noch mal
ein hilfsmittel ist und dieses einhalten
der regeln ist das a und o wir müssen
uns dem virus nicht irgendwie ergeben
sondern wir können gegen dieses virus
ankämpfen so dass also um das kanzlerin
merkel in der pressekonferenz im
bundeskanzleramt gerade vor wenigen
minuten zu ende gegangen und über die
ergebnisse möchte ich jetzt noch mal
abschließend sprechen mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten theo koll in
berlin
theo du hast die pressekonferenz ja auch
mit verfolgt die bundeskanzlerin war da
sehr erpicht darauf dann noch mal zu
sagen dass sie darauf guckt was gelungen
ist das hat auch gerade spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach bei
uns im stream gesagt er guckt darauf was
gelungen ist jetzt ist es unsere aufgabe
mal zu schauen was vielleicht nicht so
gelungen ist wo würdest du da sagen da
ist noch luft nach oben
also ganz zentralen natürlich das
beherbergungs verbot bzw touristische
reisen in deutschland also da hat man
einfach ganz klar sich nicht geeinigt
zuständig sind die länder die
ministerpräsidenten und da hat jeder
eine eigene sicht auf die dinge sie
haben unterschiedliche lagen sie haben
unterschiedliche infektions lagen sie
haben unterschiedliche wirtschaftliche
interessen
je nach touristischer bedeutung oder
anderen es gibt auch politische
überlegungen wie beispielsweise in
sachsen anhalt stehen landtagswahlen
bevor da will man seinen eigenen weg
gehen auch mit blick auf eine sehr
kritische afd
also insofern ist die einheitlichkeit
die man sich eigentlich gewünscht hat da
nicht gelungen und das wird auch sehr
deutlich in diesem in der wiedervorlage
das heißt man hat gesagt wir schauen wir
lassen sie jetzt mal laufen
wir wollen ja auch verlässlich sein
während der herbstferien damit die
menschen zumindest wissen auf welches
chaos die sich einstellen und dann kommt
auf wiedervorlage am 8 november also am
ende der bayerischen herbstferien und
dann wird man überprüfen wie die lage
sich entwickelt hat also da ist ein ganz
klares defizit wo man sich nicht
geeinigt hat und das wort hat sie jetzt
nicht in der konferenz bestätigt vom
unheil also sie hat ja offensichtlich
auf dem tiefpunkt der verhandlungen
heute irgendwann gesagt das reicht so
nicht
und insofern ist das auch eine ganz
klare beschreibung dessen dass es da
nicht nur positive maßnahmen gehabt
natürlich hat man einiges beschlossen
aber sie hat versucht das auch
auszugleichen im grunde durch sehr
starke rhetorik also dass appellativen
an die bedeutung dessen und dass jeder
mitmachen muss also mich zitieren noch
mal ein paar der begriffe es ist eine
jahrhundert herausforderung die lage sei
ernst exponentielle anstieg den muss man
den griff bekommen sonst nimmt es kein
gutes ende also ich meine das sind schon
das ist schon starker tobak und zeigt
dass die kanzlerin die eigentlich
ausgebremst wird von den
ministerpräsidenten weil sie nicht
zuständig ist und dass sie zumindest
über diesen weg des appells etwas
erreichen will ihr kanzleramtschef helge
braun hatte im vorhinein von einem
historischen treffen von einem
möglicherweise historischen tag
gesprochen war das jetzt heute so ein
historisches treffen und waren das so
historische beschlüsse
nein das war ein weiterer schritt ich
werde diesen diese aussage dass
kanzleramtsminister eben auch als ein
versuch im vorfeld allen beteiligten den
ministerpräsidenten und auch der
öffentlichkeit klar zu machen das ist im
prinzip extrem wichtig ist dass man sich
einigt jedenfalls aus sicht der
kanzlerin und des kanzleramts aber
nochmal das ist
im grunde bei nicht zuständigkeit sagt
man dieser tag ist unglaublich wichtig
dass wir uns einigen
das hat nur zum teil funktioniert sagte
theo koll unser hauptstadtkorrespondent
nach einem langen abend des ausharrens
auf die ergebnisse der beschlüsse von
bundesregierung und der länder ich
bedanke mich bei allen beteiligten ich
bedanke mich hier bei euch und ihnen
fürs zuschauen für die kommentare die
teilweise auch sehr ausgewogen waren uns
wo sich menschen das finde ich gut
ausgetauscht haben ich bedanke mich auf
jeden fall für diesen live stream und
sage dass zum nächsten mal
in diesem sinne und tschüss